[Music]
hello everybody and welcome back to
after show my name is Mark Ellis and
today we're talking about the
Mandalorian season three we're gonna hit
the finale hard we're going to talk
about the whole season and what it means
for the future of Star Wars a lot of
deep Dives a lot of burning questions
gonna get answered in that vein there's
going to be spoilers so if you've not
yet seen all of the Mandalorian season 3
please maybe hit pause on this maybe
bookmark it for later
thank you
this is the way
and our very special guest today he
literally wrote the book on Star Wars
released a book on Star Wars why we love
Star Wars author Ken knapsock you can
grab that book wherever you enjoy books
and book buying currently he also is the
host of four Center podcast alongside
Joseph scrimshaw Ken you do a lot of
Star Wars talking and force center is
such a great hub for you to talk about
this galaxy far far away that we love
and now we get to talk about Mandalorian
season three we do uh thank you for the
plug up top uh if you wherever you enjoy
books including swap meets garage sales
is probably where you'll find mine I
actually took why we why we love Star
Wars to a couple of those like buy a
book or like take a book leave a book
for free one of those neighborhood
places yeah up in Seattle oh beautiful
I'm getting a start of the Pacific
Northwest for you it's nice to know that
the trash man is in the book for his
collection that's pretty much like us
visiting another planet it's a lot
easier to do that Intergalactic travel
in Star Wars and we see a lot of it in
mandal Warrior in season three so before
I get your thoughts on the overall
season I kind of want to get into this
backwards and talk about that finale
episode that I just caught last night I
watched it twice not because I had to do
the show today but because I was riveted
by the battle by the themes by the good
versus evil but also what it meant for
these people who were formerly on man to
war displaced all over the Galaxy many
different factions and now they're
finally back it appears to have some
level of peace for the moment at their
Homestead yeah it was a I think a
satisfying conclusion to this season
which was asking this question of not
just can Mandalore come back but how and
and what that need what needs to happen
for for that to take place and and how
that comes together and had some just
some fun pew pew pew action which is
what we need and even shot in a way
including some of the wipes like return
the Jedi's Battle of Endor like it took
a lot of those things off yeah and as we
we gave the spoiler alert up top but the
whole season is 87 fresh so we'll talk
more about that the entire run of the
show thus far as 91 percent Fresh So
audiences have been on board with
Mandalorian from the start as far as a
wrap-up of the season do you feel like
what we saw in the season was
highlighted in the finale do you think
that it was a fitting culmination I
guess of everything that we've witnessed
up to that point yeah absolutely I do I
I really think this was actually one of
the most focused seasons and and if you
go out there in the discourse space you
might not hear that uh it definitely
went different places the plot had its
own pacing it did its own thing Favreau
along with the writers that you know
felony and Familia the people that he
works with but Favreau has a certain way
of painting go back to swingers this is
a slice of Life guy like he he's going
to write little scenes here little
scenes here and they're going to come
together and I think that sometimes gets
forgotten and I think this this was
there was a driving theme in this uh
season like I just said that all came
together here into this this exciting
you know dare I say pulse pounding
episode uh that had some of the biggest
action and and uh you know again
satisfying for me well it was sort of
like you know you you build this nice
house okay the mandarins have built this
fantastic place on this idyllic looking
Planet but then stuff happens we have
evenings like the night of a thousand
tears and for one reason or another for
maybe many reasons not only do they get
displaced from their home they get
driven off into these different factions
of either religious beliefs or how
strictly do we adhere to the code you
have that working in the background but
the action up front and center at the
season finale is Moth Gideon trying to
build this clone army of him in the
Homeworld of Manowar where the man of
orange are trying to replant their flag
so it's it's all coming to a head and
you mentioned all the pew pew pew action
it's a lot of pew pew pew it's also a
little bit of now din grogu kind of uh
matriculating with his ways in the force
oh man that's been one of my favorite
things the yes yes no no of it all it's
just been one of my favorite bits uh and
I know that's going to be a little
different going forward we had a
short-lived ig-12 existence but I was
there yeah no the action told the story
the final episode was was about the idea
of together versus alone mouth Gideon
represents the sense of self to the
point where he is his quest for power
just means I just want to work with
clones of me he's like a stand-up comic
quite frankly he's like I'm just on the
road with myself this is good versus the
idea of together Mandalore fell uh time
and time again because it was shattered
that was been dealt with many many times
and and so I love that that was at play
the action told that story I love the
stuff of the dark Savory it's the broken
cycle of violence with the darksaber
where that was actually uh used as
something to unite but really was mostly
used to divide it's a sense a false
sense of power for the Mandalorian
people that they now can move on from
and that's that's what Mandalore needed
to come back and be part of this Galaxy
and it was really exciting to watch just
the the odds I guess that our Our Heroes
our Rogue band of Heroes was up against
because not only do you have moth
getting in this suit that would rival
anything that we've seen in Star Wars as
far as just a protection goes we also
have these these beskar alloy storms
Troopers that are not necessarily going
down easy no unless you got a flying
Hammer from the armor
love that uh Emily swallows great as the
armor there's a lot of questions about
the armor character that I love asking
but man at the end of the day just Wang
Wang Wang that was a lot of fun actually
and it did look like I mean again like
I'm a huge sports fan as are you and so
it looks like you have a lot of
iconoclastic personalities coming
together this might have been like the
78 Yankees where you have a lot of
different people from a lot of different
walks of life but they're all Yankees so
you have all these folks who have
different beliefs within the Mandalorian
code but they have to come together
because I may not agree with you but the
enemy of my enemy is my friend and we
saw a lot of that through this final
episode as well yeah it brought home
we're not talking about the overall
season yet but there's some stuff that
was put out there about uh pluralistic
societies and how you best can come
together to make this happen this is
what need happened this idea of bocatan
was by prophecy a chosen one to bring
peace but it was beyond that right and
and her her statement of mandalorians is
stronger together it wasn't mandalorians
and apes are stronger together when we
learned but it's it's important it's
important it's how they needed to come
back because they got it they're
different Mandalore is different going
forward they've been a violent culture
her sister was uh you know murdered in
front of her by uh you know someone that
she helped put in power Maul all that
kind of stuff from the Clone Wars and so
it was uh playing with uh to change is
big in Star Wars but this season was
about trauma recovery on a larger scale
than just the individual and I think
that that's one of the things that was
brought home in this finale and unlike
uh my and your lifestyle of stand-up
comedy on the road where you are very
isolationist you needed to have
somebody's back here and to watch the
way that den and Beau Had Each Other's
back and it was really kind of
solidified for me in this final episode
where Boca Town puts it all out there in
front of everyone she's like look I'm
one of the reasons why moth Gideon is
here and is able to do this is because I
surrendered I thought it was the right
play to do at that time it I felt it was
the only card I had left and the fact
that that Den is talking with with Bowen
they have that intimate a conversation
about like I have your back and then we
see that happen in that final action
sequence when it's if if she doesn't
have his back he's a goner he doesn't
have her back he's gone if Den grogu
doesn't have either one of theirs back
they're both goners so to watch all of
that action play out it wasn't just
about how cool the battle looked it was
really what these characters mean to
each other yeah absolutely is that true
again together versus alone it's almost
stand-up comedy versus improv is what we
got here
now those worlds you're literally
talking about different sects of
Mandalorian there where we all want to
entertain audiences we have very
different codes as to how to do it as
long as we're getting the laughs at the
end of the day we're happy no I'm
imagining all the Mandalore standing
there in primary color t-shirts asking
for an occupation or a location uh and
you and I normally would decide with
Gideon here I've done both but you and I
are gideots but not in this sense of the
word yeah no it was powerful uh you're
absolutely right Bo Katan would have
been defeated uh didn't yarn would have
been defeated grogu now Den Grogan would
have been defeated acts wolves needed to
be there for that the survivors the
Survivor tribe needed to be there but I
was going out like a champ pause going
out that's how you book a pro wrestling
match you got a big guy you have a run
in by three villains to to tell the
story there
um you know so it was it was it's about
sacrifice too and all that kind of kind
of deeper things okay so we do see a
really cool battle
um on the on this barge as we're going
through it because
mandalorians they're going to a
Mandalore sometimes yeah and so they're
playing that chess game and there's
different roles and and and I love that
sequence because it did show the
competitive nature it showed that we're
not necessarily friends and we may not
be long-term allies but we're allies for
this particular Mission however we're
competing at anything it's going to come
to blows if I disagree with you and to
watch that play out as a microcosm of
how these different factions believe
their core beliefs and everybody else is
secondary I loved watching that and it
was also it kind of made me ask the
question like who is the best of the
best when it comes down to if you throw
all these mandalorians in a pit who does
come out on top I have a feeling the
result would be different every time it
could be different every time which is
part of the problem it's it's a zero
zero-sum game that we keep playing here
and that the mandalorians have been
playing they put this power in this
mythical magical sword which is not a
bad thing tar vizla creates it it's a
symbol of the community but it it's
something a yoke they've been living
under for a long time that's why I was
happy to see it break and that it's no
longer about the might it's about coming
to not even Victory Moving Forward
together but yeah that was I love that
scene in chapter seven well chapter with
23 overall of them playing Mandalorian
space chess and fighting you know
because who hasn't I always say I have I
grew up with different rules for
Rochambeau you know rock paper scissors
yeah my dad taught me that there was
also a match and when I would go to the
playground to be like match kids would
be like the hell is this Teddy's gone
crazy fighting words I can't even get
people to agree on whether you go one
two three and then you throw or if you
throw one on three and then match uh so
the match bring it in yeah it was fun to
see that stuff and grogu being sort of a
balance there uh no no no no no are you
still enjoying I mean I guess do you
feel the same way at the end of this
season about about grogu as you did it I
guess has his timeline been honored do
you think as far as his sort of learning
the ways of the force getting his feet
wet in that world but also sort of being
like I understand the force and all that
stuff and I have some Powers but also
this is my daddy and I got the scene
where he actually officially gets
adopted by DIN and becomes Den grogu you
know I don't want to be your father Ken
but you know I love me my little doggy
Molly kind of reminded me of our
relationship it did especially uh grogu
eating all the snacks as Molly does too
no I love that I love that it was an
emotional scene and and it depends on
how you read it I kind of read it as as
the armor kind of knows that's the end
result and she's kind of you know
playing the rule game and kind of I
don't know his parents are gone on and
yeah and when she says this pause is the
way I thought it was pretty uh uniquely
powerful she reminds me a little in an
odd way of Drax the Destroyer from
Guardians of the Galaxy because she's
not as comedic as drax's character is
but they have this way of speaking where
it's it's very quick it's down to the
point it's Bare Bones it's just matter
of fact there's not an ounce of sarcasm
but it drives the action and it's kind
of like okay we can all talk and code
and and use looks and she's got she's
got a mask on it's just I'm going to say
the words and you're gonna follow my
goddamn instructions yeah Emily
swallowed did such a great job with this
role she's an intriguing character she's
not perfect and I don't want characters
to be perfect she's got some questions
to answer for Farmer's got to pass she's
got a past and and she's got some
questions answered on how she kind of
raised what essentially was called a
cult they didn't identify themselves as
a cult to be fair but other people kind
of did uh and and keeping a lot of the
truth of the Galaxy from people like Dan
remember at one point Dan was like what
are Jedi Jedi oh uh I hear I've heard
about these songs of eon's past I was
thinking about these Warriors so that's
a way they did it uh that's the way they
survived and and what I loved about the
Armor's character in this um season but
particularly in the finale is uh she
changed and confirmed the changes in her
heart and and I think Favre writes in a
very direct and honest way it's not for
everyone like I said go back to the very
beginning uh Doug Lyman directs it but
he writes swingers and it's and it's
piece by piece it's scene by scene it's
Slice of Life by Slice of Life and it's
pretty sincere and it's pretty direct
and and the armor was his character that
I didn't trust at one point and and at
one point she goes you know what I've
heard and seen all the evidence we keep
getting destroyed by dinosaurs
um I've decided to change and I'm going
to that change is going to be real and
deepen me and I'm going to show up my
actions give me a hammer I'm going to
hit some Stormtrooper head and uh that's
what I absolutely loved about her in the
end that is it's such a great jumping
off point for us to now talk about the
full season too because again 87 fresh
uh the audience scored 51 rotten with
the verified audience score so it feels
like audiences have different
interpretations of this season and I'm
not sure if they felt it was just more
of the same if it didn't connect enough
to the larger Star Wars Galaxy it's hard
to get in the minds of either critics or
fans when it comes to this but for you a
Star Wars expert on Fourth Center you
guys talk about this every week
um when the season began and and really
this speaks to your point about the
armor is that we're we're introducing
these folks as far back as season one
and because the show is called the
Mandalorian and we're following this one
character DIN and he meets the armor and
they have their helmets on we as
audiences are kind of training like oh
that's the way and they say this is the
way over and over again so anybody else
who is not adhering to this particular
way we're going to look at is like wait
you're an outcast because you're not the
lead of the show you're doing it wrong
because the leads are doing it right but
this season opens up with this very
ritualistic ceremony for this initiation
to become that faction of Mandalorian
and then as you said gets interrupted by
a giant turtle and now all of a sudden
it has to be somebody like din who's had
his ups and downs adhering to that code
saving the day and you think maybe that
action in the first episode of the
season is what even turned the armor on
to maybe there's a different looser way
to go about things yeah absolutely and
and the question of trying to get into
the minds of audiences and critics
that's it's it's impossible and
everyone's going to have their own
thoughts and pennies and more
importantly their own interpretations
I'll never take away anyone's opinions
or interpretations of the art I'm here
to talk about the art of this show this
is a piece of art that was saying
something one of the things I think it
was saying from the beginning was we are
going to retake Mandalore we have to
analyze how in this question of what is
the way we keep saying it it's a good
catchphrase to put on your Kia as you're
driving down the road this is the way
honk honk but analyzing it and one of
the most important moments in the show
this year is you have this Ceremony this
Ragnar of Isla or Paz Ragnar we don't
know how their naming convention goes
now but he's adopted in the house Vizsla
the ceremony is interrupted it's
interrupted by what I keep calling it
dragon attack River uh front yeah let's
move here let's move to it's called
Zillow said it's dinosaur attack River
that's great yeah the property is awful
low here for something as beautiful oh
because they have dinosaur turtles so
that interrupts it but then later on we
come back to that moment where he loses
the dark contest to groco just a
wonderful cute moment but that that was
that's what I'm talking about the the
inherent it's important to train it's
important to you know just because
you're a pacifist doesn't mean you're
not going to defend yourself or defend
others but this is kind of the
Mandalorian culture it's win or lose
right that's how we look at Society
unfortunately too many times and Star
Wars moves past that a lot it shouldn't
be about win or lose Ragnar loses to
Grogan we're all celebrating he mopes
and goes to the river and is taken away
by this pterodactyl Monster and they go
chasing them and this is their way this
is the covet the covert's way and they
run out of pack the jet fuel pack they
all land and pause business assistance
line that I think is also kind of
unintentionally funny but it's really
tragic he looks off as his adoptive son
is being taken to his death and he goes
that it always gets away with our kids
and that's the moment the Boca Town goes
this has happened before
I don't know what why do we live
dinosaur attack River
and and Boca Tango's flying off and
that's one of the moments when the
armorer kind of has this revelation of
my way is getting us destroyed we can't
keep surviving here we must find a new
way forward and for Mandalore to be
retaken and rebuilt it has to be done
differently this is why I also think
chapter six of this year a chapter 22
overall the Jack Black episode is
actually a pretty important episode
because it's talking about if you want
to go to this direction to rebuild
Mandalore look at how this is happening
this is a World building episode that
took time with different cultures and
how they interact and how you
communicate with them and how you bring
your own baggage to different
conversations with people and and a
season that's about how do you recover
from trauma both on an individual level
level and a cultural societal level how
do you rebuild it's not just simply
Reaching Across the aisle with people
that vote differently but understanding
everyone's needs and I think in that
moment is well Ragnar's being taken off
Wesley Kimmel being Wesley Wesley Kimmel
and Jimmy's like I can't do anything
nephew I can't do anything Jimmy's
writing jokes about it he's got a show
to do uh he's going off and it's in one
of those moments where our own way we
have our beliefs we need our beliefs
they keep our beliefs keep us strong
they keep us they help us survive but
it's not going to get us over uh the
finish line so to speak and again I
don't mean to talk about it in wins and
losses but it's not going to move us
forward Star Wars is about moving
forward it's about the old and the new
coming together that's been in place
since A New Hope the old generation's
got to help the newer generation it's
got to be their fight but you got to
take from the past as you move forward
and combine it all this season was about
that time and time again every episode
built to what we see how Mandalore can
return not just going to pew pew pew and
winning right and as the season opens I
mean I'm thinking okay we're our Quest
this season is to take back our home
planet now in order to do that we got to
make sure the home planet is inhabitable
in the first place because there's a lot
of stories there's a lot of rumors on
the interwebs going around about
Mandalore set foot on there I have no
idea can you take your helmet off is it
is your face gonna explode load and so
when we actually go there we see the
Living Waters and to see to see dent I
mean this is a full circle moment for
din I know you just got back from Europe
and you probably had some experiences
where you're looking at Big Ben or
something and you never thought oh my
God I'm finally here it's probably the
same thing for din being in those Waters
and finally getting to he he has a
bigger life than he thought he would
have with raising the child yeah but
having that sort of it's not it's it's
you know I don't want to belittle and
say just this Boyhood fantasy of of
starting for the Yankees but it's that
moment where his life has come full
circle and he is actually doing the
thing that he feels his life's Quest has
been and now he gets to be restored in
the eyes of the most stringent faction
of mandalorians oh yeah no that's all
great and by the way yeah uh over there
you know when I held that uh ham and
cheese crepe in my hands and went all my
life that's what you wanted when you go
when you get to Paris in Paris I was
like all my life is built to this moment
there yeah I think that's one of the
things I loved about this season is it
moved beyond what had been presented of
the first two seasons in terms of just
format where I think a lot of people you
could have thought hey the return to
Mandalore is going to be key we couldn't
even saw that in the trailer but it's
this idea of din's got to get his uh his
his juice back his mojo back and that
happened right away early and didn't
spend an entire season changed and again
confirmed in his changes his actually he
was a steadfast character who drove a
lot of bocatan doesn't sweatpants Boca
tan doesn't get off the throat unless
he's there uh Grogan doesn't move
forward unless he's there there's a lot
of things that that din was the reason
for because he was now a steadfast
character in who he is and who he wants
to be so I think that was one of the key
things as well now I'm thinking about
the ham and cheese crepes so I've lost
my thoughts okay so it's just bigger or
is it just more natural what's the
difference between a ham and cheese
crepes there you know what I don't know
we'll get into that on another episode
of after show but for now we're talking
Mandalorian season three with four
Center host Ken knapsock the critics
consensus according to Rotten Tomatoes
which again 87 fresh on the Tomato Meter
this season is as I say it like uh Yoda
the critician census is my which may
vary by a couple parsecs as the
Mandalorian becomes more and more about
the connective tissue of broader Star
Wars lore but this remains one of the
most engaging adventures in a galaxy far
far away so I want to ask you about that
next because we do have this Quest not
just to retake Mandalore which is just
sort of you know a piece of paper or a
piece of property or a planet but it's
also about mandalorians and not just
getting back what they lost but trying
to figure out why they lose it in the
first place well what did they do wrong
it's sort of them watching game film of
their own emotions personalities and and
quirks and saying how can we restructure
that to have a safer Society for us and
our people going forward but then you do
have this broader Star Wars lore that's
factoring in where you have the the
first order of the maybe the skeleton
the foundation of the first order
starting to come to fruition a little
bit we see some spots that are post
Return of the Jedi thriving it looks
like Navarro is going to be a very nice
place to visit Coruscant doing its Vegas
New York hybrid thing but then you have
other parts that are really kind of
struggling in the galaxy and so as far
as the broader picture of Star Wars lore
what did you really take from this
season first of all I love that you're
comparing the mandalorians to the
Cleveland Browns watching the drive
footage over and over again how did this
happen
make a 1986 Sports references here this
is wonderful uh no so here's what I
think this season in my white might rub
against some some folks as well again
mileage may vary is is a wonderful way
to look at it uh season one definitely
in a lot of season two was Lone Wolf and
Cub it was Mandalorian dinjarin on on
the road by himself uh connects with
Grog who builds that connection and then
he starts to become more aware of the
Galaxy at large the show is more aware
of the Galaxy large now I think
sometimes I get what you're meaning by
connective tissue I think it's a little
danger and YouTube punches me talking
land to say that the show intended to
connect to the larger Star Wars lore I
think it's just setting its flag in the
era of what's going on five to six years
after which is why that third chapter
this season with Dr Penn Pershing and
Elia Kane there on the Encore sent which
was a little bit of a different episode
without a doubt but again this is a
season that's about trauma recovery and
you have the amnesty program the new
Republic is going forward but the it's
making some mistakes and and we're all
trying to figure out the best way to
recover from this giant thing that
happened to us again I don't know if
there's anything Society our world the
last few years it has happened to us on
a large level what did we all go through
recently that maybe favors wanted to
analyze how we recover and also it's
repeating of other things in history you
have the Galactic Civil War and how do
we all move forward from that and and
everyone's kind of plugging into the
bigger picture now it starts the first
order connections yeah we got brendell
hux we got the the dimension the return
of grand amble throw on Captain paleon
from the air the emperor empire uh
Trilogy though paleon was heard in Star
Wars Rebels so he's been brought into
Canon before it's all wonderful stuff
that's connecting to a larger picture
but this this show was still about moth
Gideon being the big bad in his
relationship to mandalorians and his
trying to take for them and take from
the culture and take like the Empire at
large take from everyone else to make
themselves stronger it's this inflated
sense of self that he's represented but
I think the show is not just pushing
into
the lore it is becoming aware of the
world that is that is what din's journey
is I'm by myself I I just do a job I'll
take you in warm I'll take you in cold
there's a larger world than I'm suddenly
becoming aware of I now have a
connection to this kid grogu that's
pushing me forward I now have a
connection to who I am uh as a
Mandalorian what does that mean to me uh
what a now that I'm pretty sure about
that now I got to get our world
connected to the society again what does
that mean to me and that's how the show
is pushing into the larger Galaxy I mean
we always looked at at mandalorians we
were all introduced to at least the
concept and the armor the same way
through Empire Strikes Back unless you
saw the holiday special when it aired
and you met this Boba Fett character and
you see oh that Armor's cool I want to
know more about this guy and I think
from that we looked at a show like the
mandal war and we just assumed this is
going to be that Lone Wolf who just goes
sort of western town to town gunslinging
doing with anybody who will take the
fight but now realizing that there is
sort of a code and there there is a
people and you have to look after and
it's really telling how specific they
are when they're when when grief offers
them basically it's like hey y'all can
show Navarro you got all your lands
there and they're like we appreciate it
we're gonna summer here uh we still need
to go back to Man the War problem with
that is that that's where Gideon has
decided I want to build my clones I want
to start an army here yeah and so from
off Gideon's perspective let's get into
that a little bit as far as his mindset
goes because Giancarlo Esposito
fantastic actor I think with more range
than people give him credit for having
said that he's very much like Gustavo
Fring from Breaking Bad and Better Call
Saul in this show where he's so cold and
calculating he's a little more animated
as Gideon but he's still great at taking
a lot of different sects of evil and
uniting them in his cause as we see in
that season finale episode where we're
all talking to Holograms and everybody's
got their points and he's like uh I'm
kind of still the I'm the leader here
yeah no I I love what he's done and he's
played as a very vaudevillian type
that's that's I think the the style of
art that fabric paints in it's this
classic Star Wars serial Adventure kind
of approach not just in the action but
even the dialogue with complete
sentences and you know before they drew
their fast breath and all that kind of
stuff and I think that sometimes that is
Star Wars uh Tony Gilroy took in a
different direction that's his version
of that time and I think a lot of people
rubbed up against it post and or which I
understand but this is this is kind of
the the DNA of Star Wars in in Giancarlo
Esposito is is so good in this this role
in these in these two episodes because
uh again I keep saying about he's a
sense of self but it's one of the
lessons of of Star Wars is who you are
is enough that's why I think and people
will maybe uh have some issues this
judge are being some of the most
important characters in Star Wars
because who he is matters everyone has
value and then you have your place in
the story uh Ewoks for you return the
Jedi fan that's what they were we don't
win without them one of the most
important moments in Star Wars is
Princess Leia looking at Wicket and
going this is an ally not an enemy let
me try to work with you that helps
topple the Empire Jean Carlos Esposito
as MAF getting represents the opposite
of that where there's nothing about him
that is enough so he wants to take more
and the one thing I've never had is the
force and of course he's not making
clones of snoke that was never in play
he it's him and his relationship that
stuff's going on yes we might get some
answers about what's going on in Mexico
we might get some answers you know it's
possible you might get a young snake
with hair and Andy Circus gets to play
that role again that might happen but
this was about moth Gideon and what he
felt he lacked he knows he's not enough
so he needs to make himself clone
himself and give himself the force and
it's about that we're on the opposite
end of it you have Den learning about
who he is you have grogo learning about
who he is you have Boca tan realizing
that she doesn't need this saber she is
enough she earns that saber a lot of
people think it's a clerical Heir that
she just was handed the sword she wasn't
handed the sword by din John in in the
end of chapter six or chapter 22 overall
she earned it because of who she is she
saved din back in uh chapter 3 or
whatever it was with that creepy little
robot a spider robot yeah that thing
went Haywire fast and that's how she
earned it who she was got her the dark
saber and she doesn't need that she's
above that uh you know like like denjarn
says I I don't care about station I
don't care about that sword it is he's
like John Cena hustle loyalty respect uh
you know you can't see me I'm Den I'm
here and that's the lesson and that's
the opposite of what MAF Gideon is every
time that's the dark side the Light Side
builds the dark side destroys and the
dark side takes and that's what I loved
about this finale was all those clones
were him because of course all I want to
spend time with is myself because myself
is the only thing that's going to get me
through this and and I'm I'm trying to
overcompensate for what I lack in my own
sense of self by uh taking power over
you now I'm thinking of that final shot
that we got in this season where it we
can finally put our feet up we got this
nice little cabin right on the edge of
town you're watching the kid play in the
yard he puts his feet up and now with
the John Cena comparison I just want to
see din jarin still keep the helmet on
but have the jean shorts like kind of
relaxed when he puts his feet up at the
end it's like the job has finally been
accomplished and I felt like this season
ended the same way that a lot of those
old comic book cereals would even before
our time where it's the world is safe
but for how long he knows that he knows
that there's going to be other issues
and and we're gonna have to come
together as a team and he reminded me of
somebody like a Michael Jordan having
that Victory Cigar where you have your
game face on and Jordan's teammates it
would even say we never knew that guy
had emotion we never knew he had feeling
until you saw him win a chip and then he
finally lets it all out that is the
Mandalorian version of finally in a
weird way reminded me of Thanos at the
beginning at the end of infinity War
beginning of end game where he did a
really bad thing he snapped his fingers
and he killed a lot of people in a lot
of planets but for him he was finally at
peace and there there's some sort of you
know happiness and kinship I feel with
it did yard looked like a guy who just
taped his first HBO Comedy Special and
he's going out to uh a cabin in Big Bear
just to relax uh yeah no I love that I
because I think you're right to say in
in season four if Avro said season four
is written and uh looks like we're going
to Carson Teva and you know Carson's
Heroes uh where they're going to be
working and dealing with the Imperial
remnants Carson Tevin has been one of my
favorite characters because he's the
first to look around and go something's
going on here
um so I'm excited to see that but but
didn't needed to get this point to this
point Dan groco needed to get to this
point where they are changed they went
through that Journey they walked this
journey to get to the point where now
they can help and look at the larger
place of the Galaxy that's that's
Mandalore as well the Mandalorian people
I bet we'll see how how how much they
get involved with everything but they
are changed as well if you know the
history of Mandalore as it's played with
in both Legends and Canon but mostly
Canon it is a warrior society that just
keeps destroying himself I keep talking
about that zero-sum game Duchess sateen
Boca 10 sister tried to change that she
was essentially murdered for it and now
they are different going forward so now
once you kind of know yourself you can
then go help others if you want to look
at that way so I love what you talk
about it is this piece but the journey
is not done it's a new chapter of din's
Life which characters do you trust the
most after you we're going to put Mando
and and Mando grogar to the side Dan and
den groeger on the side because we we're
going to implicitly trust them we've got
to know the number three is we know
their motives and that's highlighted by
Maneuvers like when din is defending
Beau to to her former faction and it's
like um hey she's the reason why she
earned the the Dark Sword yeah she she
earned this thing and they're like okay
fine
who else do you trust because beginning
season I our old friend from schmo's
know Katie Sackhoff I wasn't sure if if
we can trust bocatan or her motives but
it seems like I put a lot of stock in
her going forward yes you absolutely
should she begins this season uh with
you know once again has lost the
darksaber and feels that that's what she
needs again it's this this idea that who
I am is not enough and she learns that
who I am is enough as she goes through
that journey and it's not about being a
leader with a symbol of power it's being
a leader leader by understanding
everyone around you and understanding
everyone's needs and how you can all
move forward together I trust her I'll
tell you who I trust now more than ever
because I didn't uh was ax woes uh yeah
he came to play yeah because the the
title of chapter seven was the spies and
that threw a lot of people off uh though
Favre was not actually confirmed this
and said this we want to be clear this
is speculation but despises of reference
to the books of numbers uh The Book of
Numbers in the Bible and the 12
Israelite Chieftains who go into Canaan
to spy on the land that they're about to
their home world they're about to retake
get a little survey of what's going on
so but everyone ended that episode going
who's the Spy fair question because of
the title of the episode if you're not
overly familiar with the story of the
people of Israel uh in the Bible I think
Favre might be so uh I I didn't trust
ex-wolves but ax wolves is a real one
and he's stuck with it he stuck with the
plan and I like that he survived I also
like you're a fan of Return of the Jedi
it's the best Star Wars movie I've ever
made to this point I I like that this
season ended go with me here folks happy
Fletcher was great in the role build a
statue statue to that guy build a statue
but everyone's happy everyone kind of
got what not what they wanted they got
what they deserved their means needs
were met including Navarro including
High magistrate Carl Weathers just wants
to put a stew on and grief cargo gets
gets the the town Marshall that he wants
he wants to rebuild this city
as Ellen's got a bump in Balance you
gotta bump up and pay Babu freaking
company you know I just there's
something to me that the story's not
done but I don't know with the state of
the world I like a I like a win every
now and then I like a win so I have a
couple maybe kind of dumb questions that
you can answer because you're one of
these Star Wars experts as we hear on
Fourth Center week after week your
podcast with Joseph scrimshaw
um the different helmets or the
different the lack of helmets that's
sort of the illumination of relaxing of
the rules a little bit is that how you
read that where bocatan is now allowed
to take her helmet off in the eyes of
this very stringent armor who says
you're the one to unite everybody so
I'll let you take the helmet off but
then it seems like we're just gonna be
more accepting of everybody being able
to call themselves Mandalorian even if
they're not adhering to the strictest
dress code I think it was a great result
of of what was actually in play behind
the scenes of John Favre who had this
idea I'm convinced originally he might
have thought it was a Boba Fett series
and they were like ah we can't do that
quite yet um and he was like all right
pause on that but you know I create this
character the Mandalorian and he's like
oh they never take their helmet off and
then someone like Dave filoni comes
along and says well that's not true in
the Clone Wars we established that they
can uh and then so out of that and
there's at Star I was just out in London
for Star Wars celebration there was a
great point when Favreau gave filoni a
lot of credit and a lot of people give
the man and the cowboy hat credit and
credit was due but they were like Dave
is kind of considered this lore expert
he never says no to any idea so if you
come in with an idea my idea of the man
and the Mandos never take their helmets
off Dave goes yes and they also can so
how do we marry that together where the
Clone Wars is is you have prime minister
almec saying Django Fett's no
Mandalorian well now we have this idea
of even Boba going no here's my chain
code he was a foundling we believe it's
who you uh kind of identify as like I'm
Mandalorian because I walk the way it's
not about blood it's about the the
actions and so then you have ax woes in
that game going ah these Primitives make
up their own rules and now he comes
around and and so born out of this
conflicting uh concept over Star Wars
lore behind the scenes you get this
wonderful lesson of how we all can maybe
come together grab a grab hands on on a
hill and give the World a Coke because
you know we got some Kumbaya peace here
in Mandalore now and I think it was
beautiful so George Lucas has been
quoted as saying that you know he made
Star Wars for 12 year olds I'm going to
take it even further back than that and
felony if we're all five-year-olds and
we're all playing in the giant sandbox
floaty's the guy you won the middle
because he's going to say okay you're a
GI Joe and you're Barbie and your
Transformers and your mask can all come
together we can all have this world and
we'll build some sort of cannon that
adheres to everybody's rules so it seems
like as was first announced at Star
celebration when you were in the
audience for that filoni is going to be
directing this movie that eventually
will be the culmination of the stories
told in the book of Boba Fett and then
the Mandalorian and in the Ahsoka show
which is coming up later this summer we
get Skeleton Crew later on this year so
I it seems like we have the right guy in
charge of that particular film trying to
summarize everything that we've seen in
these streaming shows yeah and it's it's
it's pretty uh ambitious and I think
it's clear there's a lot of stuff going
out there that this is a quote Avengers
type team up movie to kind of bring
together all these shows Kathleen
Kennedy has directly said I would not
call it that Dave filoni has said season
three Emmanuel does not directly lead
into Ahsoka but it is in this time
period and it's dealing with the big
picture and thrawn's going to be behind
that so I'm excited to see where he
takes it and I know we might talk about
our favorite episodes this season but
but the second episode of this season
um is one of the things it puts out
there is this idea you're talking about
felony being five in the sandbox which
by the way I did that too there was one
day I tried to get my friends to play
MASH and I was the your Clinger your
radar Riley that did not go over well no
one had seen it I was not a felony
either if I caught the Barbies in the
bathtub with the GI Joe I knew my sister
just taking a bath and she made the GI
Joe make out with Barbie and that was
not cool with me no you just mentioned
it Matt striker of Smash does not play
in G.I Joe land though eventually they
hadn't released a figure at the Joe's uh
anyways um George Lucas says Star Wars
is for 12 year olds and what that means
is you are a young adult about to be
faced with choices and I'm going to give
you you a morality Tale on how to
navigate those choices it's not
infantile it's actually about you're
about to be an adult the idea of well
felony is just a guy that plays with his
action figures yes but those are the
stories that shaped us especially Our
Generation felonies and our generation
uh he's a Pittsburgh Penguin fan we'll
Overlook that in a Steeler fan but uh he
this this notion of there seems to be
this notion now to look down on ah
felonium Favre just play with their
action figures yes they do but think
about what you did when you were playing
those action figures you saw something
on the screen in a movie you took those
figures home with you and the morality
lessons that you took from that movie
you now then played maybe you know not
exact in the sandbox those stories are
our stories those are our culture that's
how we reform and there's depth in it
and there's purpose in it the second
episode of the season was about Boca tan
going all those stories mean nothing
they mean nothing the legend of the dark
saber the mythosaur they're nothing
they're stories we tell children they're
playing with their action figures and
then she realizes is it's more than um
it's more than that it has purpose it is
guy it's a guiding force and and it's
imagination it's how we move forward
it's how we form ourselves that was the
second episode of this season what it
was about in a lot of ways and so that's
why I'm excited to take it back to your
question about filoni I'm excited to see
where he can lead this all along with
Favre along with family yeah and long
price Dallas Howard I hope she gets to
direct more things too and how do we
move into this big episode in this big
movie to kind of Bring It All home yeah
bocatan needs to see the classic Trilogy
again because anytime you're in Star
Wars and you're in a puddle of anything
that is above your knees something is
alive in there and it's trying to kill
you
I don't care if it's a trash compactor
if it's a swamp on Dagobah if it's the
living wat they call them the Living
Waters for a reason yeah maybe it's
because there's a giant dinosaur below
the surface exactly I'm glad you brought
up a favorite episode you're doing a
better job of my job than I am no uh the
second episode of the Season really hit
it for you I'm gonna give you mine and
then you can counter with your final
reason why the second episode of your
favorite is this a debate I want
ruvicaba to ring a bell when we win
producer Christian is going to score
this one I loved episode 5 of this
season titled the pirate for many
different reasons not the least of which
is I'm a Star Wars fans I appreciate the
themes I love how the the religious
aspect of it is not it it's kind of it's
like the fourth description it's this
this ethereal thing it's just kind of in
the water it's in the trees it's around
but it's not so heavy-handed I also have
a good fight scene yeah I loved seeing
the mandalorians come defend Navarro
from the Pirates where it's Mando real
he's like okay I'm I know what my
purpose is and maybe to your point he
might not have done this same act in
season one but he's learned he's got a
kid now he is defending the people who
have helped him he's defending grief
cargan his people who are just trying to
to get away from that old kind of life
you know and so now you have this
invasion of pirates and they're
hell-bent on Revenge and they're coming
in and we stop them I love that action
sequence but the other thing I really
loved in that episode was towards the
end it reminded me of Jaws and I don't
think it was lost on any of the
filmmakers in this particular episode
that Teva is is just cruising around
town he's just driving around blasting
his Tunes got the top and the X-Wing
down and then he sees this what that
that looks Imperial but it's not
inhabited and there's a blast hole in it
and it reminded me of in Jaws when they
find Ben Gardner's boat and I'm waiting
for the body of somebody come right
there and we realized that that was
Gideon's uh transport and that he's not
gonna make it to trial this guy got out
somehow it was such a cool moment late
in that episode that that's the one
where I was like I really appreciate the
quality of the craftsmanship that goes
into making these episodes that felt
cinematic to me yeah and I think just in
terms of feeling like this is on the big
screen season three as a whole might
have been the best job of doing that up
to this point for me yeah look even the
final battle of of chapter eight unreal
yeah yeah and I think the stagecraft the
volume has improved I still you know I
love the look of Andor a little bit uh
more than some of the stuff in the other
shows I cannot wait for the World At
Large to see the acolyte footage that we
saw at Celebration uh Leslie headland's
got a great show in her hands I'm
convinced and it looks wonderful it was
shot a little differently but the volume
the stagecraft of it all has definitely
gotten to this wonderful point where it
does feel cinematic and I do love that
scene because it's that it's that you
know you're yeah Pirates and you know
gorian shards defeated veins runoff to
go join Skeleton Crew as a cast member
and and uh I got another gig I'm doing
the the Chuckle Hut on Tuesdays uh and
uh I I yeah I really love that I just
love uh Paul Sony and him as a performer
and him in Star Wars such as wonderful
Star Wars fan and see him as Carson he
always says the right thing but he's
also he's like I know what the right
thing to do here is but I'm gonna go
have a drink first yeah yeah and I have
some questions yeah I have some yeah
exactly uh I have some questions about
how uh you know the new Republic
judicial system is like hey get in show
up today anyone know where he is ah then
we'll figure it out uh there's some of
those things watch Batman yeah right you
just got to take out the Joker sometime
but these shows aren't necessarily about
uh that I would say Star Wars did not
does not want you to ask how or what
first it wants you to ask why and
there's some great purpose in that there
too that's and that's a great episode
it's just um it's just kind of fun and
that's also the episode that has the uh
amazing uh uh flashback right to is that
the one that has a flashback to Keller
and back I can't remember now or is that
chapter four uh I'm at best return think
that flashback was enforced what was
episode four we'll let the cop it was a
woman on this episode by the way and let
us know your thoughts on season three
what was your favorite episode I'm
taking the pirate we're figuring out
which one of mad best had to Triumph and
return to Star Wars canon in uh just
quickly what you just said was it it
always strikes me when I'm learning
store we're sitting at your knee and you
talk about the why is the most important
in this galaxy far far away what was the
why about episode two that really got
into your bones was it just you you felt
like okay now we're locked in we know
where there's the season is going to go
um actually uh we what what I loved
about it on a surface level was that
after that episode I didn't quite know
where the season was going to go because
I and maybe I was mistaken of looking at
oh this I even saw a joke that someone
was like oh I guess this season's going
to be about din trying to go take a bath
you know just and it's the same kind of
criticism but Fellowship of the Rings
are just people walking got it we get it
you're you're a wonderful Barb from an
early Kevin Smith movie but uh but let's
move past that because by the way even
Kevin Smith will move past that stop
playing hockey on the roof and get a job
yeah um no this mine's a Mandalore uh
you it it opened up the season for me
where again this season was it was
highly focused on what it set out to do
we need to return Mandalore and how do
we do that and and why do we need to do
that and that episode uh so I I loved
what we to go to Mandalore as a Clone
Wars fan with spectacular uh to go there
but again the stuff with Boca tan just
her going these stories mean nothing it
was a very meta episode because it's you
and I have grown up you grew up we grew
up in the 80s we were told put aside
your childish toys put aside your
childish movies and grow up you'll never
make any money playing video games yeah
and look I want you know maturity and
growing up that that's that's the thing
it isn't about that I keep saying pop
culture is our culture we were raised on
this stuff this formed who we are Flight
of the Navigator form formed you more
than some Edgar Allen Poe book all right
okay and and for Boca tan to be like
none of this it was all Pomp and
Circumstance we put on a show for people
uh nothing there's nothing down there in
the Living Waters there's these this
story let me read you this plaque it's
silly and for her to learn that that's
not necessarily true now in the show
it's because of mythosaurus it may be
real did she see it did she not see it
but it was a story for us to go all this
matters you grow from this you learn
from this it affects your lives and
that's why the minds of Mandalore is my
favorite one this season that's a that's
a great mic drop not just for season two
or episode two but also this entire
season three as to what we learned the
feelings the the expectations that were
subterfuge in a good way for you and I
think for a lot of folks out there you
talked about how this is the way as the
Mandalorian kind of Catchphrase it works
for a nice bumper sticker uh you have a
great bumper sticker that's two words
where you always encourage Star Wars
fans out there to enjoy thinking about
what the future could hold but speculate
responsibly is is what's going to be on
your Tombstone here let's get an abstuck
it's been great responsibly so I'm going
to ask you to speculate responsibly a
little bit here season four is there
anything that you are you don't want to
get too attached to anything I know you
well enough to know that you don't want
to start writing your own fan fiction
that would somehow undercut what you
actually see in Mando season four is
there any any character any storyline
anything that you hope you get to see in
that next season I do hope that it
pushes more into what's actually going
on with the new Republic whether or not
we see mon Mothman Leia we're going to
see mon Mothman Ahsoka but that was my
one of my little critiques of this
season Amanda too many people walked
away from it thinking that the show was
saying New Republic Empire they're all
the same that kind of thinking gets us
into a lot of trouble check the
intentions check the intentions of of
the new Republic not perfect but I think
their goals are better than absolute
oppression
so I I think I want to find a little bit
more of that as they try to you know
again the Galaxy is recovering and how
do they deal with that and as far as
people names yeah we're going to thrawns
and play uh seeing brindle hux was great
for a sequel fan uh Trilogy fan like
myself when he says project Necromancer
yeah that's what we're talking about the
guy it could either be them trying to to
just get the the vassal for the spirit
of of Palpatine and that could lead
directly to stuff and who knows even
notice where the moth Gideon refers to
that where that's like he actually
sounds Gideon sounds like somebody like
like in the 60s who's like building his
garage full of robots and some guys
talking about the internet and he's like
uh good luck with your little project
there I got these robots ready to go in
the garage yeah yeah yeah absolutely
yeah very sci-fi um so I want some of
those characters one of my favorite
characters out there that uh has not
shown up in anything other than uh books
comics and video games which is a lot
because I read those and play those
games too as a character of a grand Emma
Ray Sloan she was this wonderful
character introduced in a couple novels
and she is one of the ones that kind of
leads the remnants out to the uh final
um the unknown regions and she's an
interesting character because I call her
uh in my book why we love Star Wars that
you so thankfully mentioned available
wherever you enjoyed she's the good
villain she's for the Empire but you
understand her reasons for thinking that
Law and Order and security was needed
but then she discovers that that's not
it's not maybe in line with her way of
doing it and she's important and she her
end has not been answered yet so I would
love to have her in season four men to
learn as they try to deal with what's
going on and there's more and more
characters that have made that Journey
from being born out of books or video
games into this Star Wars Canon as far
as the TV shows and movies go thrawn
being a prime example where we've seen
him in Rebels where we're all talking
about him in in this show moth Gideon is
he gone for good is he like Jason where
he just kind of disappears in a fire and
then he's just gonna show up again at
our doorstep look Star Wars is uh it's
never be certain about people being gone
he he could show up nobody's ever really
gone no one's ever really gone and I
again it's the why but Palpatine
returned to show you that the dark side
never lets go refuses to change refuses
to let go of its own power Gideon could
be that but I I take it as spiritually
dead like it's he's dead and that was
the lesson it was about him and his
relationship to Mandalore and what he
wanted and that is his end the dark
saber 2 I think could be gone but you
could rebuild that but it's a different
version of it it's played differently
never put your clones in the hallway on
the way to where the final battle is
gonna be you can't have you not seen
multiplicity you hide them above the
garage in the shed so your wife and your
kids have no idea that you're cloning an
army up in the I'm glad you mentioned
that because I'm pretty sure there's a
moth Gideon around there going I like
pizza so there's a Steve Dave my mom get
in up there we can talk about star Wars
and particularly this episode of and
this season of Mandalorian season three
all day we are out of time but that
gives me a great conduit to invite
everybody out there once again comment
and let us know what you thought about
this season was it your favorite do you
love where the show's going do you have
questions uh Ken can usually answer them
on his show for Center which you can
catch every week you and Joseph
scrimshaw talking about all things in
the Star Wars Universe breaking down
what happened and also the why of it
where else can all the kids out there
check you out Asus include my website
kidnapps.com occasionally there's this
hack comic that takes me around the
country with them uh and we do we do
sadly little skits this fall yeah this
fall so look for that and uh yeah
hopefully a comedy EP coming out soon
and yeah why we love Star Wars which is
a celebration of the greatest soccer
ever told and you can pick that up
wherever books are sold for Ken knapsock
the whole gang here at Rotten Tomatoes
I'm Mark Ellis reminding you all to
check out rottentomatoes.com that's your
Hub everything from movies to TV
everything in between including when we
might get some more Mandalorian Ahsoka
Skeleton Crew there's a lot of cool
stuff coming your way in the galaxy far
far away and if you think those movie
announcements at Celebration didn't get
me out of my chair and walking around
the apartment a little bit I'm really
excited for all three movies that were
announced so tell us what you think
about all these things in Star Wars and
more right now thank you so much for
tuning in if you're on YouTube click
that Bell it's going to give you a
notification every time we got a new vid
drop And subscribe right here I'm Mark
Ellis saying as a famous bumper sticker
once did this is the way
foreign